na prawo i sprawiedliwość obiecywało
100.000 chyba mieszkań w takim programie
mieszkanie plus
który okazał się totalnym niewypałem obiecywali
i okłamali i nigdy nie zrealizują tej obietnicy
my jako lewica patrzymy w przyszłość i myślimy o tym
żeby ludzie Po prostu czuli się bezpiecznie
swoich mieszkaniach
ale moi drodzy
jeżeli my jako lewica mówimy o mieszkanictwie
o tym Jak powinny być zaprojektowane te osiedla
to powtórzmy to
300.000 mieszkań
na tani wynajem
w dobrze zaprojektowanych osiedlach
gdzie każdy z mieszkańców czuje
że to jest jego miejsce na ziemi
gdzie ma dostęp do usług publicznych
gdzie ma dostęp do komunikacji
że może dostać się do centrum
że ma możliwość odpoczynku
ponieważ są ławki
no nie wiem czy wiesz
że są takie osiedla w polsce
gdzie ludzie nawet nie mogą usiąść na ławce